it's a long way from the alamo but an la
restaurant owner angela marsden called
out her city's mayor for shutting down
her outdoor business
while allowing a hollywood movie crew to
set up a similar dining area
just yards away i'm losing everything
everything i own is being taken away
from me and they set up a movie company
right next to my outdoor patio they have
not given us money and they have shut us
down
we cannot survive my staff cannot
survive tell me
that this is dangerous but right
next to me is a slap in my face this is
safe 50 feet away
mayor garcetti and gavin newsom is
responsible
for every single person that doesn't
have unemployment
that does not have a job and all the
businesses that are going under
and we need your help we need somebody
to do something about this
now if she were a famous actress uh
she'd be working
she's not so la's nannies closed her
down
eric garcetti says his heart goes out to
her but not on a plate because you know
restrictions are necessary
unless you're a hollywood film crew
because in the land of dems only the
rich and powerful thrive the little
people get crushed
you just know hollywood will thank
garcetti maybe with a star on the poop
encrusted sidewalk and that's why you
get into politics or entertainment when
bad stuff happens
you're always first in line for relief
or exemption
on saturday night live pete davidson
said this about these staten island
protesters
the rule is that they're supposed to let
people eat or drink outside
and the owner said no one wants to do
that because they'll go out of business
but the argument that people in staten
island don't want to drink outside can
be disproven by going to
literally any little league game they're
making us look like babies
now he said all that before a live
studio audience so he's doing exactly
what those protesters want to do
work so how did pete get around those
restrictions to mock those who couldn't
snl paid audience members 150 bucks
ahead
to show up making them hired extras
if only a restaurant could do that they
can't
meanwhile the butt of many elitist jokes
guy fieri is doing more
than any city leader to help out the
restaurant tour
launched a relief fund raising 21
million bucks for 43
000 workers i await a response from
those restaurant critics who love piling
on the cheesy mayor of flavortown
but none of those hacks could help
anyone with a real job
so as one mayor destroys small
businesses while playing favorites to
the rich and famous
a foodie helps the little guy or rather
thousands of them
harley would make a movie about that
they won't
so i want to play this uh sound on tape
from admiral draw
he's the testing czar talking about the
data and outdoor dining
what really breaks my heart is that i
don't know of any data that says you
need to shut down
outdoor dining or outdoor bars we really
wanted to limit the
indoor crowded places so i think we need
to do what's necessary to turn the
pandemic
but not more that's not evidence-based
so degen why do politicians adhere to
this idea if there's no data behind it
does data not matter
they don't have the data the contract
tracing is for crap
and they are ignorant and arrogant and
incompetent and won't admit that to the
people they govern
and these business owners these
restaurant owners they built
these dreams just based on hard work and
grit and determination and that hard
work grit and determination
can't save them from the hands of these
politicians
i you know people politicians have
always said oh small businesses are the
heart and soul
of america well they don't have hearts
and souls so how in the hell do they
know what they're even talking about
i was raised the child of small business
owners my parents ran a small
wholesale grocery in in the south in the
rural south
and they always knew because of their
size
that politicians didn't give a cold dam
in hell about them because they weren't
lying in their pockets so the big got
ginormous
and the small as you said got trampled
on
my mother knew that it took other small
business to try and
save their own and that's what right
before she died she said this
i wish i was rich so i could give it all
away
and anybody who has a job who hasn't
missed a paycheck
that's exactly what we're all doing
meantime these politicians
need to get their asses fired
you know uh dana uh getting a hundred
that's a pretty great idea 150 bucks
ahead to go watch uh a show and just
because you you get around all the
regulations by hiring them as extras
pretty sneaky well imagine if the bar in
staten island
had enough cash on hand to pay
its customers to come into the bar then
i guess they could also
get around the restrictions somehow i
imagined um the it's interesting
admiral gerard says his heart is
breaking angela marsden's heart
is obviously broken and nine million
people have watched that on youtube
eric garcetti says that his heart is
broken
if everyone has broken hearts americans
we can't do something about it i know
we'll talk a little bit later about
help that could come from the government
but i do feel like something is
happening greg
this pandemic is exposing
government to a whole generation of
young entrepreneurs
who will maybe they have again big
hearts
but they will realize that a
conservative viewpoint on smaller
government
is the way to preserve liberty and their
ability to make a living
yeah you know geraldo it is kind of
weird to see politicians
deciding who are non-essential workers
there's a certain irony to that
you know i i totally agree with dana
about the need to rethink
government's role greg but you have to
understand i have two grandchildren
in los angeles county they had 25 000
cases in california yesterday alone 9
in l.a county and garcetti and this is
the land of the fires and the earthquake
said that this the covid thing is the
greatest threat to life in los
angeles that we have ever faced i think
that
you know you got this vaccine coming
down the road i feel for these people my
dad owned a coffee shop and a diner that
went broke
you know right in brian kilmeade's
neighborhood on long island i get it i
understand
my heart breaks for angels she's one of
the most articulate spokespeople
against the clumsiness of a big
government and
the illogic of it at times but we have
to understand there is a desperation
here
these guys these men and women the the
that are elected
they they want to save lives this is
we've never faced this not
since 1918 have we faced something where
you got people dying left and right
every 30 seconds an american dies you
got to give these people
a little slack here yes they're
intruding on libertarian
values and and it's bad that saturday
night live is mocking them but
give me a break here i don't think
jesse my issue is that they're being
mocked by people who have no skin in the
game
we can criticize all the restaurant uh
uh owners or anybody who's losing their
jobs because we get to sit here
and we get to talk about it and we get a
paycheck pete davidson gets a paycheck
his company paid for his audience
yeah i mean isn't that how people get
paid to go to your show got failed
i thought isn't that how you got around
it anyway no i agree no i agree with
both of you and geraldo
if saturday live had been shut down
which i think donald trump would have
loved but let's just say they were shut
down permanently and pete davidson
was just starting out he had to scrape
by had no salary and was forced to go
underground to do his little skits in
front of small
crowds so he could make ends meet and
then was arrested
and thrown in prison for just being
funny
i would have had his back you would have
had his back staten island would have
had his back
but the same thing is happening with the
pub owners and he doesn't have
their back and to geraldo's point
geraldo
you can protect the sick but you also
have to protect the healthy
and right now you're having politicians
basically create
a covid caste system where some people
are treated like peasants and the rest
are treated like royalty
so if you're as an actor you can eat
outside
but if you're not an actor you can't eat
outside i mean you can bust
down a business's door but you can't
open the door black lives matter can
protest but trump people can't
and to say that you're doing it to save
lives well how many lives
are they actually saving with these
restrictions seven out of the top ten
states in the united states with the
highest death toll
are run by democrats so california has
done multiple shutdowns multiple mass
mandates and they're going way up so if
you're going to shut people down at
least pay him the cash
nancy's holding back the purse strings
they're playing with what a
a trillion five with that kind of money
you could pay each
restaurant owner ten thousand dollars a
month
just to close doors and do takeout but
instead they're saying no no
you're gonna shut down we're not gonna
pay you and then you have to watch an
overpaid actor eat a burrito right
across the street from your shut down
restaurant
meanwhile omar's husband omar's husband
just got over a half a million dollars
in bailout relief
and he doesn't run a restaurant he runs
a political
consulting firm during an election year
and he actually applied and got the
money but they can't get the money at a
restaurant
wow i didn't know that oh my god yeah
that just that just came
out that'll be on tomorrow i bet